Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambhodassa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and Fully Self-Awakened One.
So the question was, what was the Buddha's greatest discovery?
There are lots of people who follow Buddhadhamma, they get a lot from the practice and the teachings, who themselves are some form of materialists, atheists, scientific materialists and so on.
You can understand how they get the benefit from it, because you don't have to believe anything.
That's the great thing about the Buddhadhamma, you have to explore it yourself.
But it does baffle me that some people sort of deny the transcendence of Nibbana or of the Buddha's achievement.
He himself referred to himself as the Tathagata, which translates rather badly as thus gone.
But the best translation I've seen is the transcendent one, one who has transcended.
What's he transcended?
Well, he's transcended suffering, he's transcended samsara, but I think it goes much deeper than that.
So, involved in that is also perhaps a wrong understanding about the teaching of not-self.
um in the discourse on the teaching of not self he simply asks you know if you look at your body what can you control you know we think we are the body we think with our emotions but we find ourselves ruled by everything and there's very little thing there's very little i can do about the lack of hair on my head it's a bit late anyway never mind
and then there's all that business about impermanence and if something is impermanent then obviously it can't be substantial and so on and so forth right i'm sure you all know that so what i want to do is take his victory verse so that's the first thing we'll look at and this is what he says through many births i wandered in samsara the world of suffering
Seeking but not finding the builder of this house.
Painful is repeated birth.
So this house, of course, he's referring to himself.
The heart, the psychophysical organism.
Oh, house builder, you are seen.
You will not build this house for me again.
All your rafters are broken.
The ridge pole is shattered.
My mind has attained the unconditioned.
chitta he used the word chitta we'll come back to that and i have reached the end of craving okay so here he's using a metaphor for the self the house builder and through the house builder we build this world that we're living in this is our house when you think about it you see everything is happening within your body within the mind and then we project everything
onto the world i mean it's it's sort of magical really so we're in this bubble of consciousness our own little bubble of consciousness and it's up to us to make it a fairly nice place to live in it and and and we've made mistakes in the past led by delusion and made a hash of it to some extent or another
so what he's saying is that once he's found the cause of this house that's built which is the self right this this delusive idea of a self then he was able to escape all the suffering that that delusion um makes made for him now this word chitta you see the problem for the buddha was that he had discovered something for which the language
couldn't express and i'm not so sure any language can but he's stuck with words that have other meanings so he'll talk about the chitta chitta means the mind the heart mind it's the emotional and thought life what we might understand by the greek word psyche and but here it's obviously not that because
the psyche as we know it the body heart mind complex is conditioned but he says he's he's attained the unconditioned citta so he's pointing to something which is beyond our psychology and beyond our physicality and he re and he reinforces
what produced that which was of course the destruction of all the defilements my mind has attained the unconditioned unconditioned means that or rather conditioned means that whatever that is relies on something else for his being there a tree relies on oxygen and so do we yeah
we rely on food being gross so that's what conditioned actually means and our minds are conditioned by the society the things we we put into ourselves so we're in constant interplay with our environment which includes other people but he says this is unconditioned right so it's something that doesn't need anything else
right and he turned and he calls it the chitta which in a sense gives it a certain substance now he doesn't like doing that so it must have been a bit of a pain for him to say that because that's one reason he doesn't like the self so this self is the atman of the hindu system well the brahminical system which referred to an eternal soul
and there was huge confusion at that time as to exactly what it was and there were materialists that people said you know when you die that's the end of it so he stuck for words but he clearly states that whatever he's experienced once the house builder had been completely destroyed was unconditioned okay
By the way, Freud, with his insights, had a similar problem.
He had to make up words, didn't he?
Id, ego, superego.
Now, there's a very famous teacher, some of you will know him, I think, Ajahn Mahabua.
He died not so long ago.
And he was understood to be an Arahant.
He definitely said of himself that he no longer suffered.
now in one meditation and i think this might have been the point of his release from suffering he uh he's in meditation and he's in that that place of just observing etc etc and he says this dharma this teaching arose in him spontaneously and this is it if there is a point or a center of a noah
anywhere that is the agent of birth the essence of continual becoming and that's exactly what the Buddha discovered himself so it's something that we also will discover in time that whenever the self arises the world arises and we go into that world which is
unless we are completely purified of defilements, is a cause of suffering for us, unsatisfactoriness.
Now this isn't something that is ethereal.
Every time we wake up in the morning, that process happens.
You wake up and you immediately recognize yourself.
And many of you, I'm sure, have experienced waking up in a strange room, in a hotel or somewhere, and you don't know where you are.
Just for that one moment, there's this little frisson, this little burst of fright.
You don't know who you are.
And then suddenly it's you and you feel safe again and happy.
So that moment is telling us that there is a point as we wake up in the morning where we take on this sense of self.
okay i just want to you can go on you can go on about this forever you know so i just want to talk about i just want to point out another way that he describes nibbana and these this comes from the uh inspired sayings there's a collection of his inspired sayings the udana sutta
So it opens, it just says that at one time the Buddha was staying near Savatthi in Jeta's Grove, an Atopindika's monastery.
And he was educating, encouraging, firing up and inspiring the mendicants with the Dharma talk about, now this is the word you see, extinguishment, okay?
But what we have to be clear about is what is actually extinguished.
And these mendicants were paying attention, applying the mind, concentrating wholeheartedly and actively listening.
then understanding this matter on that occasion the buddha expressed this heartfelt sentiment there is that dimension where there is no earth no water no fire no wind so there's no of the four basic elements that means there's nothing physical no dimension of
infinite space no dimension of infinite consciousness no dimension of nothingness no dimension of neither perception nor non-perception those are the four
what we call our rupa jhana that the four absorptions the non-material absorptions which is the most refined state that the mind can get into where there's nothing in the mind of the body at all not even images of the body right so there's not even that so there's nothing from the physicality and there's nothing all the way through the mind
there is no this world no other world no moon no sun yeah so there's nothing there at all there mendicants i say there is no coming no going or remaining or passing away or reappearing so there's no time and there's no space
just this is the end of suffering and he uses the word dimension so this is another way that he describes consciousness ayatana it comes up in the dependent origination and it's normally translated as the consciousnesses are based on the sense bases
so you have eye consciousness ear consciousness nose consciousness etc and you have heart mind consciousness okay and in the five khandhas this consciousness is just a screen upon which information arises and that screen is dependent upon those six sense spaces he's saying that there is a dimension
that is beyond all that and he often refers to it as nibbana and I'll leave you with a final one we've just got a bit of time here so again the mendicants are paying attention they're applying the mind concentrating wholeheartedly and actively listening and this is probably the most famous statement or the most well-known shall we say
There is that which is never born, never lived, was never created or bound by conditions.
If there was not that which was never born, never lived, was never created or bound by conditions, there would be no escape from that which is ever born, ever lived, ever created and bound by conditions.
But since there is that which is never born, never lived,
never created or bound by conditions there is an escape from that which is born ever lived ever created and bound by conditions and that's that's really his chosen way of expressing the transcendent by telling you what it's not and of course it's up to us now in our meditation practice to turn our attention towards those three characteristics
because that's where we will ourselves discover this dimension to see impermanence right to really see it and to see that there is a mechanism in us this desire which is born out of the self is an expression of the self causing all these problems and that sense of not me not mine
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, they have not caused confusion, and that by your diligent practice you will indeed break through the delusion and attain Nibbāna sooner rather than later.